this was just after 7:00 a.m. this
morning on the Aegean Sea between Turkey
and Greece a Greek coast guard vessel
passes close to the overcrowded dinghy
of migrants moments later from another
Greek flag boat not clearly identified
as Coast Guard a man hits people with a
pole women and children are visible on
the dinghy these are people who've been
encouraged to make this journey by the
Turkish government who stood down there
border guards three days ago
as it draws alongside the larger vessel
a guard on board raises his weapon
moments later shots are fired into the
water
it's known as a push back it's more than
controversial it's illegal Greece has
made no comment but in the past has
argued that it's so overwhelmed by
migrants it has no choice on the Turkish
coast where that boat left from more
prepare to leave Turkish buses have
brought them here all part of President
Erdogan strategy to pressure Europe in
the Turkish capital he defended his move
and with extraordinary figures for the
numbers he claims have crossed into the
EU since we've opened our borders people
heading to Europe number in the hundreds
of thousands the number of people going
to the border will soon be expressed in
millions on the river that marks the
border between Greece and Turkey there
are people crossing but the numbers are
a fraction of what the president claims
driving along the Greek side of the
river to see the numbers for ourselves
we spotted almost no one
the Greeks say 24,000 people have been
intercepted pushed back 4,000 along this
river the rest down on the Aegean Sea at
one official Greek border terminal the
authorities were keen to show us that
they are holding the line beyond the
barbed wire is the no-man's land between
the two countries crossing into Bulgaria
which also shares a long border with
Turkey again no sign of the numbers well
we're back on the Turkish side now
having travelled the length of the Greek
side of the border into Bulgaria as well
and while we have seen some migrants and
seen video of others crossing they have
not crossed in nearly the numbers that
the Turkish president is claiming on the
Turkish side of that official crossing
we've been out earlier more tear gas was
fired by the Greeks over the fence and
further along the border
a Syrian was shot in the face by the
Greeks it's claimed there they denied in
this chaos it's hard to find the truth
and still they keep arriving like this
family from Idlib in Syria they tried to
make a life here they told us but then
the Turkish president told them the
borders to Europe were open the draw for
something better is
huge here and so in this political game
Turkey has created a sense of chaos
Greece has been pushed to desperate
tactics and these people are stuck
miserably in the middle Mark Stone sky
news on the Greek Turkey border